la crise belge allez vous vous mettez là
enora et isabelle morini-bosc blum était
là-bas et marion et gérard vous êtes en
couple en cours avec elle oui encore ça
vous allez vous voulez vous voulez
changer
oui oui c'est vrai et vous le rêvez
cyril l'a fait oui alors je vous
explique un petit peu le jeu je vous
posais des questions vous avez également
jouer chez vous sur la vie de couple
dont la réponse est forcément un chiffre
vous allez noter ce chiffre sur la
pancarte ceux qui seront le plus éloigné
devront faire des bisous sur le visage
de l'autre avec beaucoup de rouge à
lèvres donc mettez tous déjà du rouge à
lèvres même vous jure oui mais allez-y a
les armes étaient toujours ouverts je
vais vous dire vers un max wimax je tue
c'est dire que j'aime pas les blondes
mais le couple le coureur qui aura le
couple qui aura le plus de rouge à
lèvres sur le visage aura perdu et devra
se faire un smack boulud d'ailleurs on
en change tout de suite les équipes
hommes et bertrand avec marion et
isabelle morini-bosc avec jean-luc i say
party on tourne on fait trois couples
alors attention
enora gérard est ce que vous êtes prêts
noram et et de rouge à lèvres voici la
première question ce sont de vraies
réponses vous pouvez jouer chez vous que
nous on joue pour un bijou
après faudra vous embrasser tous les
deux il va vous embrasser n'aura vous
inquiétez pas ça va très bien se passer
d'accord c'est une aura qui s'occupe de
tout vous c'est bertrand qui s'occupe de
tout et vous il semble qu'ils s'occupent
du tout bon c'est sûr lui qui s'occupe
de vous d'accord alors attention
quel pourcentage de français a déjà
cassé de la vaisselle
lors d'une scène de ménage allez vous
avez 5 secondes pour répondre vous
répondez soit au campo car celui qui est
le plus loin a perdu je joue quel
pourcentage de français a déjà cassé de
la vaisselle
lors d'une scène de ménage aller très
vite car il est terminé s'il vous plaît
allez n'aura s'il vous plaît alors à
votre avis enora et gerard smith a pour
165 combien 20 % 20 % et jean-luc 35% et
la place à celle là
s'est enflammée je compte ceux qui
seront le plus loin devront se faire on
joue pour un bisou là ce sera sur le
front des versions bien pour ça qu'on a
mis des chiffres pas possible eh bien le
pourcentage de français qui a déjà cassé
la baie c'est lors d'une scène de ménage
c'est de 19% célébration après si vous
perdez complètement il y aura le smac
voilà il faut qu'il soit recouvert et
moi aussi je l'embrasserai à les y voilà
attention on joue maintenant pour trois
bisous ceux qui seront bien sûr mais à
la fin ceux qui auront le plus de bisous
ont perdu devront se faire et se faire
le goût du smart module attention en
moyenne combien de fois les couples
français font-ils l'amour par mois ou là
en moyenne combien de fois les couples
français faut-il l'amour par mois 5
secondes pour réparer vite vite s'il
vous plaît si vous ne répondez pas aux
cinq secondes est éliminé et le plus
loin à perdre
attention c'est vrai que c'est terminé
je termine même jean-luc logan bailly
combien 7,6 pour six fois par mois il a
fait comme si ce n'est des 8 x 8 fois
par mois et vont 4 4 fois par mois
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut c'est éclate
oui car en convient c'est si c'est pas
tous les ans on a fait comme bon lui et
bien sachez que les français font en
moyenne 8,6
d'anjou
bisous bisous à deux ou trois bisous
voilà pas fait aussi trois bisous ah oui
ah oui oui oui
attention on joue maintenant pour quatre
bijoux à mon avis tu fais exprès de
perdre toi
allez vous savez qu'on va même jouer
pour sibi sibi zoom attention ces mails
ou bien il faut que je me déshabille
alors
j'ai faim la souffrance jouer avec nous
ce goût essayer de répondre
voici la question ceux qui perdent là
auront perdu un joli ah bon ah oui alors
c'est sûr la gnaque et élaborant ses
labos gauche à qui il a beaucoup changé
combien de fois se dispute en moyenne
par eau
cette étude compte toutes les disputes
de la toute petite à la grosse
embrouille
attention vous l'avez sur une seconde
pour réponde de combien de fois un
couple se dispute en moyenne par an nous
en aller si elle évite 5 secondes
cette visite médicale et s'il vous plaît
de son côté n'aura jamais allé s'il vous
plaît enora girard vous avez des couples
à enora girard vous avez découvert 17 17
fois par an
130 fois par an qui a raison
les couples selon une étude très
sérieuse a coupé n'aura 10 et déjà je
vous le dis la dispute
les disputes les plus fréquentes ont
lieu le jeudi soir à 20 heures selon une
étude c'est le jeudi soir le programme
de télé me tchessa exactement eh bien
les couples français
c'est simple les couples se disputent en
moyenne 312 fois par an une fois sans
doute repenser et nora gérard tu perdras
pas
bisous bisous est ce que vous les heures
un petit mot d'abord ses ambitions avec
enora d'abord et après les bijoux pour
que la madame tussauds allez c'est parti
à l'est
on se bat ce match avait allégé
attention à moi je dirais cela qu'il va
falloir être happé de girac
est ce qu'il a fait à minuit
merci coûter très cher